if you're looking for a gift for an
architect in your life
don't be one of those people that get
some lego
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about some of the
best gifts that you can get for an
architect
in 2020 there is a million and one
things that you can get for somebody
i trolled the internet for a few hours
looking for some of the
best suggested architect gifts out there
and
99 of them are terrible from an
architect
to another potential architect watching
you probably know what i mean
there's people out there buying you
little lego blocks or
model bricks or concrete soap holders
all of these items are well and truly
good
but no architect really really wants
them
so if you're watching this looking to
buy a gift for an architect
today we're going to talk about 10
different products that might be perfect
for that person in your life so we're
going to start with
five tech related gifts that are very
specific to the niche of architecture
and the first one is of course a good
keyboard and mouse
if you know anything about what that
architect friend does all day
they more than likely sit at a computer
for 12 to 14 hours a day
just creating a way so this means that
they really want to be treated
and that extra couple hundred dollars
they spend on a keyboard and mouse combo
could be the difference between them
having couple tunnel and
major major risk problems in the future
to not at all
so this is my number one suggestion to
anybody looking to buy a gift for an
architect in 2020 moving on to the
second gift idea and it is the dji
om4 now this is the brand new gimbal
released by dji
i'll bring this one to your attention
today because architects
are having to create more and more
content in order to be able to promote
themselves as a personal brand
architects are being labeled as brands
now more so than anything
it isn't you go to a firm you go to a
very specific architect
so as architects we are creating more
and more for ourselves to be able to get
more and more clients for the firm
number three is one of my most used
tools
and something that i'm going to be
upgrading to very very shortly
it is the apple ipad pro with the apple
pencil
2. the reason i specify this product
here and
not any of the other ipads is for the
simple fact
of refresh rate screen brightness and
the compatibility with the pencil i
currently have an ipad air
it is the older generation i have to
have the old generation pencil
and the screen isn't very good whereas
at work we use the ipad pros the screen
resolution
is significantly better you can see the
details in the drawings and the
responsiveness of the pencil is much
much sharper
not to mention the fact that you can
easily snap it onto the side and charge
it
whilst you're talking during a meeting
whereas with the older generation you
have to stick it into the bottom
and you can't just pick it back up and
keep going it is a bit of an awkward
experience number four
if the lucky architect in your life
works at a rather large
practice with lots of people surrounding
them then
more than likely they're going to need
some good headphones to dry out the
noise
and pay attention to their work so
there's a number of options here
depending on the phone they use you can
either go with the apple air pods or you
can go with the sams and galaxy buds
alternatively
you can get a set of beats by dre that
are over the ear and cancel out the
noise extremely well
number five is the tech home gift for
all architects and creative tech nerds
it is philips hue lighting with a number
of different solutions
you can get them to just have fun at
home i personally purchased philips hue
lighting for my home it's in the bedroom
it's in the study here
and it's just a creative outlet
basically
now moving on to the next five products
they're all a little bit quirky
they're all a little bit interesting and
they all vary from very cheap to very
expensive
in the exact same category so i'm not
going to specify
anything for each individual product i'm
just going to give you a generic
recommendation here
they're all very useful for architects
and if you have an architect in your
life you're going to know why
pretty quickly so the first product of
choice is a 3d printer that's
potentially a laser cutter and a cnc
machine as well
the more we start to create and design
and the busier we get in life
the less time we have to physically
model at university architects have to
model
hundreds of different of little projects
and little homes out of cardboard and
styrofoam and wood
you genuinely just don't have time for
that in the real world
so a 3d printer becomes a great useful
tool
for any architect looking to model very
quickly and very rapidly
number two going back to my very first
point
and the simple fact that we work in a
chair and a desk for a very very long
period of time
so number two is a good ergonomic chair
and i think
anybody that sits down in an office for
a very long time can appreciate this
gift
number three personally speaking i do a
lot of travel as an architect i travel
five six hundred kilometers
every other week to visit my projects
and to visit my clients
so a good leather duffel bag is
extremely important
i personally don't have one but i find
that the more and more i travel
the better it would be to have something
that you could quickly pack
carry on and go now this is one of those
items that varies from relatively cheap
to very expensive
depending on your preference depending
on your style personally i think there's
a couple good options out there so
whatever you choose
i'm sure it will be a good choice number
four
is wireless security cameras for your
house they're very easy to install
they're tech related gift
which most architects will love because
we are all driven
by technology most of the time and yet
they are something that will keep us all
safe
and last but not least is again
something relating to
never being at home and never having too
much free time and that is a robot
vacuum
more so than not i'm having to find
myself quickly running around the house
cleaning it at the end of the week and i
just genuinely don't have that time for
it especially in the busy periods of
christmas
so having a robot vacuum would be a
greatly appreciated gift i'm sure
by any busy architect in 2020 anyway
that's all for me today guys thanks so
much for watching i hope you enjoyed the
video
i hope you got some useful information
out of it and some good gift ideas
if you did make sure you smash that like
button to help others with their gift
ideas
smash that subscribe button to see more
of my content and as always
i'll see you next monday